monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mesdames les ministres mes
chers collègues
alors oui l'histoire s'était rappelé ce
matin plusieurs fois a fait de la france
un grand pays de la vaccination pasteur
mais aussi albert calmette camille
guérin ont jalonné l'histoire de ce pays
on est montré tous les bienfaits de
cette vaccination que l'on attend ton
face à la corrida
alors oui il faut vacciner oui il faut
inciter à vacciner c'est certain et
d'ailleurs je crois que parmi les débats
qu'on pourrions avoir erré question de
la gratuité générale de la vaccination
de tous les vaccins prise en charge est
évidemment conscience disparaître un
jour la tva sur les vaccins ça sera la
meilleure façon là aussi d'inciter à la
vaccination
en ce qui nous concerne la sur le débat
de ce matin face au virus de l'aco vide
moi je vous rejoins de ce mini sur un
point pas de vaccinodromes anxiogène
parce que tout acte médical doit être
solennel alors il faut être opportun
saisir toute opportunité s'appuyer sur
la proximité la confiance
les médecins généralistes les
pharmaciens ils ont démontré d'ailleurs
en officine avec la vaccination
antigrippale comment ils ont pu capter
une patientèle qui ne serait pas
forcément aller se faire vacciner contre
la grippe
donc il faut saisir toutes les
opportunités là où il y a la confiance
pour effectivement donné envie à nos
concitoyens de se vacciner
évidemment si on veut être partout la
question de la logistique va être
essentiel la logistique et les stocks
des guerres se sont perdus pour des
questions d'intendance
alors il va falloir s'assurer tout à
l'heure vous avez évoqué le mécanisme du
rnb sagem je voudrais surtout qu'on
puisse parler du messager qui va porter
le bon stock de suffisamment de vaccins
partout en france pour que effectivement
tous les territoires ruraux les plus
isoler les territoires ultramarins on en
a parlé ce matin puisse aussi être
évidemment bénéficiaires de ces vaccins
la question de la logistique va être
essentiel dans les tout prochains jours
et puis la question des stocks est ce
qu'on va pas là encore être face à une
pénurie
l'impréparation de la campagne vaccinale
antigrippal 2020 2021 est à
l'illustration des question qu'on peut
se poser ici dans cinquième puissance
mondiale où il faut contingenté et nous
avons aujourd'hui encore le 17 décembre
des listes d'attentes pour de délivrer
des vaccins anti grippe et donc moi je
voudrais qu'on y voie clair et on va
attendre votre réponse tout tard
monsieur min sur les sujets de quels
sont les stocks réels aujourd'hui
disponible dans ce pays n'a entendu
parler de 200 millions de doses
peut-être que ces cinquante fois moins
et c'est là où il va falloir quand même
qu'on soit très clair sur le calendrier
et puis il ya la question de qui
vacciner et là je suis le ministre ya
quand même deux trois choses qui nous
choque
vous avez employé un terme d'ailleurs
qui a créé beaucoup de confusion depuis
le 27 octobre est essentielle
il y aurait les essentiels est donnée
essentielle ça me rappelle quelque chose
pour moi toute vie est essentiel et donc
s'il n'y a pas de problèmes de stocks y
a pas de question de priorités
assureront la distribution partout et
les sont effectivement la possibilité à
chacun de se prendre en responsabilité
d'aller se faire vacciner comme tout
acte médical au quotidien et c'est là où
la notion de priorité elle doit pas
forcément être par classe d'âge bien sûr
je comprends la question le sujet des
ehpad seul ministre un ami
comment la question aux ehpad un mort
sur deux en ehpad c'est encore il ya
quelques jours présidente département
pourrait effectivement vous parler du
fonctionnement des ehpad et donc il ya
une vraie difficulté un vrai point
faible
à ce niveau là est donc très bien mais
je crois qu'au delà des questions d'âge
et c'est là où les médecins généralistes
et spécialistes ne les oppose ont pas
sont tous un rôle essentiel il doit
pouvoir définir leur niveau de priorité
parce que les questions d'éco banc de
mort dit et elles n'ont pas été évoquées
encore et pas en tout cas par vous dans
leurs détails sont essentiels l'asthme
d'insuffisances cardiaques le diabète
avec surcharge pondérale donc ces
questions là ne sont pas forcément des
cages des questions d'âge mais bien des
questions médicales elles doivent
relever du médecin j'espère que nous
réussirons ce défi ce ministre en tout
cas je le souhaite je le souhaite parce
que c'est l'intérêt de tous
dans 200 jours en juillet 2021
nous fêterons le 100e anniversaire de la
première vaccination par albert calmette
et camille guérin contre la tuberculose
j'espère que nous aurons le succès que
leurs travaux ont permis à faire
progresser l'humanité
je vous remercie de votre attention